it's a very good question because I've
been thinking about it a little lately
and I've been approached by some younger
people ask me what I think about that
and one of the things that I would say
they didn't get until I was a little
older is to get into a business I don't
care if you love it doesn't have that
but you have to get into a business said
that provides you with cash flow because
to be in business world and to grow you
need money and the axiom that the rich
get richer is very very true because
opportunity comes to the people that can
take advantage of it or opportunity
seized by the people of that can take
advantage of it and I had every step of
the way I had opportunities to save more
money and I didn't so then when certain
opportunities came my way I wasn't
actually able to take advantage of them
by the time Magnolia came my way I've
smartened up but it took me towards 40
where I had a very successful
construction company that threw off a
lot of cash I saved a lot of it I
invested it and save that money so when
Magnolia came my way and I had to put up
over a million dollars cash I have it
now that could that sounds like a lot of
money and that took me till I was 40 but
if I'd been saving and investing in
doing that since I was 22 when I started
being an entrepreneur I would have had
that amount of money much sooner and
been able to take advantage of other
opportunities sooner now I don't regret
it because life leads you where it's
going to go and magnolias a wonderful
opportunity and probably one of the best
ones I could have gotten
one regret that I have about not going
to college is when I look back in my
life that for years I would have given
up in my mind it was giving up time that
I could have been doing business and
becoming this world famous businessman
in my mind that I gave up this wonderful
time you have as a young person to
explore yourself to explore your
intellectual and creative pursuits
without the pressures of being in the
world and I do regret missing that and
at the time it seems so unimportant and
so important for me to get into my life
I thought I was going to wanted to have
as being a businessman but looking back
at it there was no rush nothing that I
did between the age of 20 and even 30
ultimately other than give me some
experience and really made a difference
so if I taken even six years to go
through four years of college or went to
graduate school my life that's nothing
would have changed and what I was doing
I don't think so I think it's important
to say in school for those reasons but
it's not for everybody and I understand
why people leave
you